I'm outside King CMI left eye we are
headed to Long Beach to do a little
location scouting for the next corridor
digital shoot we are looking for an
awesome backdrop in a completely fall
swallow and a completely new location
that we haven't shot it before a real
dingy place for a bad gun deals ago and
sweet backdrops let's go find out we are
in the ports of Los Angeles in Long
Beach California got this warehouse with
dock locations super quiet kind of doing
some test shots of the camera but
looking to be a good option we've got
our Devin Supertramp Signature Series
glide cam courtesy of Devin Graham thank
you
we're getting some pretty cool shots
with it probably talking over them right
now you're looking at beer old now this
location you get a much better view of
the docks back there and there's also a
couple more things to hide behind for
the tiny gunfight which is what this
video is all about well we see a road
down here that could be even better so
we're going to go down there this place
is a little bit busier this is an active
Seaway terminal so ships are incoming
and outgoing right here for businesses
and so it's a little bit more active but
you are right by the water it's pretty
cool
you're not supposed to be under taking
pictures is private property
oh you can't be out here taking pictures
we were driving out of the last location
where I ran into that security officer
and we found this spot the problem is we
don't know whose lands it's belongs to
we're looking around looking for signs
looking for signs of life looks
well-maintained I'm guessing that it's
city of LA or city of Long Beach because
there's a board of L a building right
there but can't be back it's pretty
great I'll show you this spot again we
found a really good location on the ends
of the docks
yeah this is port of LA this is port of
LA very low traffic right here this
entire area right here is just not in
use at all okay okay public street with
public parking right here we're going to
be on the other side of that street do
you think others thought you mean like
over here yeah we looked we looked
around you can see all the docs and the
hangars and stuff there totally I will
tell you one other spot so everyone on
the bar because I think there's a
fundamental thing here which is why
drive all the way down to the docks when
you can't see the docks for work can we
film a weekend there's also parking
spots right here but you're going to get
some traffic right here yeah we just I
mean we saw a car drive but every once
every like five minutes on the ending
around long that's cool
now that's cool because you get the
trees that are there we'll be able to
see the water real easy and you can see
the docks I'm excited yeah this is an X
so the only traffic you're going to get
are some people that work in this
building just coming in I feel like they
coming drop offs and leaves yes I make
troubles and leave oh hey well completed
the set Oh tiny gun we're gonna do the
whole video in the day oh yeah one video
one day that's my new rule you don't
work on youtube if you can't you'll they
don't make you this video to be
answering video today because just
commit this is going from guys that have
taken six months to make videos
Christian what what are you doing with
this this is your friends and you're
just trying to give it back to him
yes today we have been shooting some
brilliant shot when we're down in Long
Beach right now and it's this tiny
little dock it's really given me these
like great like Miami vibes everything
about this spot is just gorgeous so this
is definitely I think one of my favorite
videos as far as like just purely how
it's worked
oh also fun fact as you're watching
through this video you might notice that
almost every single shot is a shot with
the 70 to 200 lens I'm specifically
trying to make every single shot this
very compressed telephoto shot close-ups
are all for close-up you know everything
is just squished in together into these
frames
now let's easy people to come six
thousand million dollars so much money
just act super cool and do cool things
don't rush it and act then turn around
face camera like you're scouting the
mouth while gigolo three two one oh yes
that production though me and Jake found
this awesome location near this pretty
inactive warehouse we're kind of just
here stealing the shops and then getting
on getting our shoot done but you're
always nerve-racking when you're halfway
there and you started and you don't want
to get shut down and ruin your whole
vibe but Harbor Patrol has been driving
by all day people think camping out all
day no problems even the cops came up
turned around the drivel wid they didn't
give a we go through a lot to make these
videos but you know who goes through
even more as our patrons
I talked to Kristen Goya aka Ren is mine
called me up and he said Jake I'm
literally in the air on a motorcycle
right now flying down to a flatbed truck
and that's what I'm doing to support you
guys now who was in that truck Timothy
Thompson yeah he had the flatbed truck
he was blasting down a downtown street
at 80 miles an hour and rent his mine
landed in the back Timothy Thompson hard
on the left-hand turn her he's holding
on he's holding on boom and guess who
joins them
Sean Witt shows up in a police car he's
like you guys we're gonna catch him were
the tryna catch so Hawk lie that's right
he was up there he was in the tank James
Bailey was in that tank with him so hot
guys driving James Bailey's in in the
middle he's turning the turret around
dude what are they going to do with that
tank somebody stop him thank God Richard
Blackburn was there because he made him
both slow down pull over safely to the
side of the road get out and then they
all shook hands and went their separate
ways and they said continue to go on
make great videos and we said thank you
thank you for your support one of the
dollies could be here moving that way
what are the shots
well basically right now we're playing
around with like a lot of like zooms and
really intense ramming we start like
zoomed out completely have characters
move into perfect focal length while
doing like zooms up to them and stuff
and it's very coordinated looking shots
basically simple here
don't worry about anything after that
how's it being in Miami it's great you
know other than the hurricane threat and
the threat of rising sea levels oh dude
red eyes breathing heavily no thank you
let me see man are you okay good it's
good
I wasn't expecting that
oh you dashed over yeah I would come out
we got a he'll be on that's good gnarly
cut right there like oh yeah I know that
[ __ ] hit the curb yeah yeah he's my
contact here King see em I left I how do
you feel Oh fine man I just can't see
him I left I right now it's just foggy
oh yeah I know it's just it's open yeah
let me let me stop the bleeding and
probably your Adrenaline's probably
[ __ ] jacked up if we're dealing with
laceration level business Oh
like it's just it's good no I don't I
don't want to give them affection see if
we can get the bleeding to stop
yeah then hit it with some water to
clear your eye out yeah just give me a
minute
just go sit down on the shade well I'm
glad you're fine but I I do care about
your face quite a bit just make sick of
these they can see because they don't
don't rush it don't don't sweat it
I'm dead time I knew the moment I had I
felt this help us bust over did you fall
on purpose and I totally just got
dripped pat down with her you tripped on
the curb yeah what is your head just the
ground I just yeah I just I hit like my
it's good at least it reach you didn't
hit the curb you hit your head on the
ground art I highly put excites there's
a little bump for sure of it it's good
I'm doing great it's gas you probably
need to do when you get home and I
superglued Reconstructor butter or a
butterfly band-aid I don't think it's
like just small enough where you want me
to stitches in this [ __ ] dude your eyes
that say I don't need a stitch I do you
want a small scar rather than a big scar
you should probably really sick what the
band-aid can't be in the shop dependent
issue but you sit here don't do anything
we'll set some stuff up a little
disappointed slam my face against the
concrete perfect you're going to have a
lot less of a scar if you get stitches
this your scar will be wide if you can
get stitches it'll be smaller
well that's literally the only time
whether or not we could shoot more - yes
we could but he [ __ ] killed it I'm
not going to ask you to be any longer
okay all right
what is serious playing register because
we see the ground otherwise in my
glasses in this shot you killed my
partner you son-of-a-bitch erase the
Jake
then I rap yeah sir rap sup Nick any
cool videos you seemed lately yeah
you guys remember that video going to
the store or is like a Shirley wonky
like motion capture well today they just
came out with a third one that he shot
while he is in Japan but time for sushi
time for sushi some really good VFX work